previously on raft do i get a hat i want
a hat i don't think i don't think we
need to listen to him i have found my
hat yes and as my first decree of
captain i need a sail hey i built the
sail
that's five points look at his shirt
captain he thinks he's number one above
you even oh my goodness then he gets one
point wait a minute why is your shirt
say six but your name says seven because
my shirt is six and i am one i gave you
six points i'm deducting seven i'm going
to build a very special captain's thing
and you two don't look weighed i need
you to come here and i need you to uh
think about something any concern that i
might starve to death or dehydrate while
i'm in it's just five minutes captain
i'm currently in the middle of placing
two additional harvest nets me placing
them now
it's time to pick another captain the
winner wait where where are you
god i'm there i'm here all right well it
doesn't matter because
it's a bomb
now that i'm in charge
it would be a little different okay
all right let's get this out of the way
hey listen to distractible
or i'll [ __ ] find you no it's uh
we're not mad if you don't listen we're
just disappointed
and mad but you know what if you do
listen
good for you good for you
i hear that listening to distractible
makes your penis bigger and or become
yeah it makes your penis and or vagina
bigger both of which i assume are good
am i the captain is that what we decided
no
i'm captain right the captain
okay have you ever won a wheel thing
ever no i'm pretty sure my name just
gets excluded i'm going to start a
conspiracy yeah i don't think martin
right i don't think mark writes your
name in
exactly
i post a picture of it um
that say that mark or bob wins yeah
that's true it only sounds a little
sussy
oh i think sean won one time he wasn't
even there yeah i remember all right uh
i'm the captain yeah yeah uh aye aye
captain
i can't hear you
oh yeah the captain
spongebob oh i thought we're not not
gonna do it okay i have the sail aimed
to the side and we're going backwards
oh well i'm not on the boat i'm not on
the boat
it's okay
we cannot move
your sail is not aimed to the side for
me captain yes it is
oh well it was for a second we started
to move but now it's straight back for
me
apparently my eyes don't work captain
anyone uh
first mate wade do you have a paddle uh
negatory
[Applause]
there's nothing i can do about the
rockets i got a guy
sonny sonny jim
nice rock avoidance not captain
nice rock avoidance
not first mate does that mean i am first
wait i called you first mate wade oh my
captain baby
my baby captain my sweet
crap
oh goodbye cat quick
[Music]
out on this raft
for legal reasons i'm not going to
finish the song
man the net swing
the nets are manned
[Applause]
by putting wood around them you can make
reinforced things oh you know what i'm
the chef aren't i sounds familiar now
that you mentioned it hey do we have any
wood
maybe no we got it maybe maybe i'm out
i'm completely out of wood yeah woods we
could use some wood to cook some food
well we don't need to cook food we got
lots of taters
and beets
you want to don't you want to plant
those bad boys yeah but we get extra
every time so you know there's always a
an excess also those are worth way more
if you cook them anyway
well i mean but they're here
i well but i'm not like starving to
death let's just sail into some wood
come on
oceanwood i i mean i guess i could try
to paddle us forward but they cost wood
no no we should go we should go in a
straight line
this stuff starts to stuff starts to
spawn in front of us right right that's
a straight line so we should just keep
cruising all right your captain is about
to start starving to death but oh
nope there's a shirt oh yes that is the
thing to be concerned about is food and
or water beets beets captain
sick beets
incoming not incoming wait i don't see
the reins
i don't have reinforcements metal you
think i got metal i don't got metal hey
someone come eat this come on
can some come
eat this food and put some wood on here
requested come come come come come come
come come come come come come come come
come i'm a cooked shark and a not cooked
fish because we ain't got no
food cooking
food cooking cookers all right cooked
shark i took it and here's an oh i have
another shark to put on what put some
cook sticks on the thank you i mean
welcome just so you know wood's at a
premium but we got tons of beets and
haters raw beets like don't even do
anything they give you food they give
you something give you a small amount of
food yeah but we got lots of them
we're getting plenty of wood don't worry
about it smash down these potatoes and
beets
there's that classic bad attitude i'm
always on about it's an average attitude
couldn't be me captain you can't have
two average things that's not the way my
folksy captain saying works well what if
it's a just have one average thing and
one bad thing and you can't have a
stinky thing if you want but that's
optional i guess i'm
oh storage we do not have much of it
no
no we don't captain got your present
he's right there oh
what is that oh a package
oh i learned how to make a cupboard
that's story for you a progress well i'm
going to open my package i learned how
to make a rug
oh we're getting some pretty decorative
things
storage oh that requires scrap and plunk
and rope what cup what is a cupboard
and how do i can you store stuff in a
cupboard
for that barrel i've been sitting here
waiting for it this whole time would you
got it
a decorative piece with minor storage i
don't know about that
anyone having a hunger
i know i got potatoes
uh oh another prison for you guys
i'm going to go in my room and open my
package okay island big island do less i
learned sunflower oh my sweet jesus yes
it is big island
you know what we're not outfitted for
what
the big [ __ ] island okay i think
we're
right captain you're not i think we're
gonna need a paddle
i have a little bit of power we might be
able we might be able to get there
actually let's see let's see how the
cruising works let's see let's see let's
see cupboard
yeah this is miner storage i don't know
if it's really worth ah i'll build one
and i'll see what the dealio is let's
just see
i'll put it in your room captain there
you go captain
thank you you're welcome oh wow it has
four storage slots hey that's something
i could keep my special cappy gear i
don't know if my big string is long
enough uh shark
oh char what is happening uh shark what
i did it we
we i you
really more i than we uh we need a uh
anchor thinking oh we can make a
stationary from that we have another
package
do we have uh hidden hinges
hinges yes i have one
how do you have how many
give give me hinge you can find them in
crates and whatnot
give me places there's five planks
more planks
oh i have plenty of requires more
plastics coming in
at this island
captain
oh my god you had so many planks i love
you
thank you how many ropes do we have i
have so many how many you need oh i need
six ropes
okay yes i'm gonna make us a stationary
anchor
can someone with does anyone have an x
per chance i
had one not anymore i have one i can't
hold it
ah i'm gonna make an anchor hole and
give us an anchor okay
and then what i'm gonna do is trade
whole captain eat these beets
get rid of the hell out of here pretty
good beats again then i'm going to make
it and make an anchor and that goes
right in the anchor hole nice
beautiful anchor hole captain
yes thank you i don't need your
affirmations but i appreciate it
hi captain beautifully said this is a
big island and there's a big bird yeah
i'm having a feeling this might be one
of those story islands and we might be
really ill-equipped for what's about to
happen
islands you say
just an inkling really more than
anything sort of a what
they say captain what they do
who says that
someone all right all right are we gonna
probably stay here a while and collect a
lot of these trees and whatnot right
well not all of them's as harvestables
but yeah there should be some good stuff
here okay i'm gonna make some more
storage so we can uh
that's pertinent that's yeah
intelligentsia i
intelligent even
that's what i just want to let you guys
know this bird from the looks of her
is going to be throwing rocks at us
we start making the good storage bins we
playing oh we have hinges and ropes oh i
have i have weight yeah i have a whole
ass load of planks fight another hinge i
could make one or i could give you the
planks
right here there's three of them in
there three hinges oh my god you guys
had metal this whole time
we have a lot of metal it seems as if
they were in the box we had metal this
whole time ah i see a
banana
man i really am out of planks just
deeply planks you say you really burn
through all these planks the planks you
say oh wow
i'll chop down some trees i have a iron
axe look
oh biscuits oh i can't chop it with the
axe i forgot oh that's right i need some
kind of weapon to do weapon things seems
like incredible are we stuck
what is the deal we're not moving i
think the wind is not with us lads oh i
almost had a surprise attack on the
fiend uh
i don't even have planks to build a
paddle i have zero planks
i can build what's it
called paddle a full engine motor
short of a paddle we need to sacrifice
some of the ship i don't know if that
returns maybe some of this girthy yeah i
don't think you get any planks back from
that
try great yeah
i got a plank oh okay
yeah
oh wait wait wait wait oh god oh jesus
i've got five planks
what else do you need plastic and rope
made it
done
holy geez
oh you're the only one
sir how badly i'm a problem solver
there's problems i solve them i'm really
fighting the current here
we are moving moving very bitly it's
just really
really against the wind i guess um
if only we had some kind of a wind sock
yeah like
like a wind cloth i see a big scary bird
perhaps some kind of wind sheet yeah
yeah that'd be nice
but alas hey you know what
battled us right in here where we need
to be
lanker is dropped my dudes oh excellent
excellent excellent this is teamwork
watch out for dick bird dick bird dick
my least favorite of the sesame seed
characters oh you guys had watermelon
seeds this whole time and pineapple
seeds i could have
oh man that would have been really
useful
the shark's not too happy here all right
i'm gonna abandon anything on the boat
and i'm going for trees
yes i'm getting i'm gathering the planks
i went left
swing right mate
right
oh swinging
wow that sounded bad dropping rocks no
yeah that's dick bird oh dick bird it's
a myth birds don't drop rocks wait how
do i
yes
catch this goat
we need a net
oh i see you i see you i see you i see
you i see you i see you i see you i see
you god
i'll defend you captain while you save
not first mate oh he's turned upon us
are you uh
you have a goat oh it's like a llama
chasing me yeah i don't know
don't worry i'll get you off this boar
mountain this island kind of sucks
captain
yeah you're supposed to have like
weapons and things by the time you get
here i think
more more
there you go oh i've been failed oh i'm
fine i feel great never better there you
go bud thank you
don't worry first mate i'm coming dick
bird is coming
zigzag i need a weapon
the polar is dead oh killed the hell
yeah the boar is born
oh he's shaking his head no
for you captain to show your dominance
of this boar llama oh i deserve this oh
i'm dead
[Laughter]
i just i was just worried about you
okay yeah you really don't want to fight
that
where did you where did this happen oh
wow
that bird is terrifying i am here down
by the water i see the wrath but i'm
further from the raft than the boar was
but right now
oh okay
really really laying out the path slowly
for me here look toward poor area right
beach
that bird means business
there you go don't wow the anchor wait a
minute okay you wouldn't leave me behind
would you get mad not on purpose
all right good camera hey i found
mushrooms
oh heck yeah ah if i had a shovel i
could dig up this buried treasure i
could try to make a shovel
this is rocks not metal what am i doing
oh my god you have planks they don't
have six planks uh i'm trying to find
more trees
oh no not much luck ow wow the bird
really does hurt you it hurts a lot i
found a recipe
but i'm not gonna tell you what it is
is it for potato and beet soup because i
know that one it is not for potato and
beet soup
is it for mystery sausage because i know
that one
i know that one
let's say what mystery sausage is at the
same time and we'll see if we know it is
okay okay okay all right all right
three
two
one a penis
i think that was what did you guys say
penis in the dark alley oh people
yeah mark and i were pretty much the
same i wait uh wait it look like penis
is people
well we're people
many things have a penis that is not a
people can i have six links
you think we have planks oh wait yeah i
have 31 planks
uh i could probably thirty one
uh not first mate his shovel i chopped
down a whole bunch load of trees and
whatnot i'm trying to find more trees i
guess you chopped them all that would
explain it climbing a mountain captain
i'm currently trying to parkour in a
cave but the stuff is not
red but not wanting me to parkour it
bird
i'm afraid i'm going to break my ass
nice oh i found the watermelon nice
oh i found a pineapple now i just needed
whoa
i was rocked by a bird keep those legs
turned there buddy this team values hard
work
dedication
and leg movement sounds like somebody's
not moving their legs hey training post
a what post a trading post
we don't have anything that you can
trade at the trading post because of how
this game works but there's pineapples
and watermelons i'm taking that's for
sure whoa i didn't know there was a
trading post
and red berries yeah this is part of the
newest update the reason we revisited
this finally is that they added these
bad boys ah the only reason yes
you know what you need to trade though
cubes of
garbage oh uh
we don't have any garbage cubes you
might think given the state of our
existence that we would have garbage
cubes yeah the other is full of garbage
a very specific type of garbage cube
i need thine planks
uh
pass
whoa
uh permission to steal wood for a shovel
captain
uh i'm coming captain's coming back
don't you worry here i'm behind i'm
right behind you i'm coming back don't
you worry you're sweet it's really hard
to get here
i'm coming don't you even worry about it
behind you
okay no i hear you i hear what you're
saying but i'm making my way i'm making
my way to you you don't need to you stay
where you are and i will find you
[Applause]
oh don't you dare sing that song to me
right now get out of here you know
that's my favorite
account i'm not gonna do it just because
you're singing the song every now and
then if you keep doing it i'm going to
jump off this cliff
[ __ ]
oh
first mate you're right behind me how
are you hey
would you like some planks i happen to
have a whole ass load
hmm sounds like someone wasn't moving
their legs captain
yeah really need to focus on the leg
movement okay not first mate all right
champ shovel shovel i don't need
it
come with me first mate i'll show you
where to i'll show you where to shove it
okay with the brown nose and calm down
uh
down here for no wait a minute oh i'm
fine
it's fine it's fine
because of magic nothing bad happened i
think i might have been drunk when i
imagined what i'm trying to find
oh
it's somewhere yeah there's a cave and
the cave is in here somewhere so don't
worry
don't question or worry about it oh here
it is
right where i meant to go i knew i was
going the whole dig this [ __ ]
back to the boat i'm gonna drop off some
stuff three dirt and a stone
oh yes
dirt you say
five dirts acquired cap all right well
that was absolutely worth our time
that's it let's get out of here i'm glad
you made that shovel first mate okay
other mate have you gone in the water
yet no i have not captain
all right new priority
water uh let's shark wait oh boy
whoa what just something else just hurt
me after the not shark gone
dying now uh my uh captain is dead oh
right next to the boat oh uh i got you
guys uh yes thank you
something hurt me other other than the
shark in the water i don't i don't
understand
the blues maybe it's a it's not good for
being alive that's for sure well get him
i'll get revenge
looking for ways to die captain what ah
there's a million days no ways to die in
the oceans
ah buying yours
the waters may be safe wow oh my god the
shark is dead harvested hey there is a
blowfish over here how do we
how do we get those to kill it before it
explodes or some such sometimes i i i
believe you have to stab it and run
it's down here in the in the you see it
i've stabbed him
again i've stabbed him once more no
don't oh
you [ __ ] ass
okay
well i'm drowning i feel like that was
uh your first mate's fault uh it do be a
doobie
you know captain i wouldn't betray you
like that
i wouldn't do sarah where are you i'm
down in the water where you got some
work to do now yes
i'm always by your side captain always
forever and ever you know what even if
you are doing a better job than current
first mate wade um
i just feel so bad for the guy oh
i see i see
this conversation
uh no you you not what no no
no no
captain turns out air is important don't
know if you knew that hot dip
don't drown drowning not good
this has been captain's helpful tips
thank you captain
oh nice song first mate you're so good
with the song everybody loves your song
robbed a lot of that from the first
mate's idea but that's all right
that's got the kind of pizzazz a captain
needs blowfish discovered captain all
right don't [ __ ] it up
oh no you know what that sounds like
sounds like somebody didn't listen to
captains helpful tips
that was a close one
well you were actually dying in real
life for a second i almost did captain
but i didn't for you well i i i
appreciate it
oh god how is he back already why god a
good spot captain well good thing i'm
not low on health or else i would be
very scared given how deep in the ocean
i am
yeah yeah having almost frowned i'm sure
you're very healthy yes yes
don't worry about me don't worry about
me
die somewhere where we can find you eyes
on the shark fish blowfish between us
blowfish acquired captain oh i love it
[Applause]
are you alive or what what's going on
well it's kind of an in-between
situation
talk to talk to cappy come on i feel
like i have many holes in my heart
oh well that's not a good place for
holes are they are the ones that are on
the inside or the outside holes oh
they're kind of any audi situation oh
that captain first mate does not have
the health to help
the not
mating of the
[ __ ]
who's alive and who's dead i'm losing
track right now i'm dead captain
alive okay barely where where is he
close to you uh can you eat some food or
something can you order him to help me
first mate
get him
all right captain
captain prepare to rescue the first man
get
get him
i captain it
aha
good that took you long enough
okay well where are you dead now oh you
know what that does mean that i'm about
to have a visitor
oh okay excellent great well i'll just
do all the hard work won't i
that we do so no it's fine huge hard
work so good man i'm really far away
from where sharks can't go
no
captain didn't listen to captain's
helpful tips about sharks ow there's a
bower over here oh sweet jesus
no
the shark of the land has returned oh
god
so much peril
get out of here you sick old [ __ ] eh
i'm gonna eat some more food i'm full of
food that doesn't heal me all right i
have have some health i really am not in
a good position to hey whatever
hey
i order me to save you
wait you know what
i'm gonna go in
i'm going to go in here and and
salvage some of my tools ooh an unstuck
button just appeared captain oh oh do
that do that that's really good not at
all safe location yeah
hey um not first mate can you help me
get the poltergeist man out of the sky
well that worked and the captain has
rescued everyone oh captain that order
incredible with leaders like these
who even needs
that's a good finish captain we got two
catfishes and salmon says oh no
take this
and then how about you
uh where'd it go where'd it go i'm gonna
need a new
[Music]
beer soon
i call that the dosey doe
i'm with you i'm with you
he's coming for the captain he's coming
for the captain never mind
dab stab at him someone stabbed me
wait what just happened someone stabbed
me i also just
i also just took a bunch of damage i
didn't stab you oh yeah about to be dead
getting out for a minute to dry off mine
don't worry i will bait him be ready to
stab he's coming oh my god
what hat what is he doing he's in the
shallows
this shark has
oh hey step uh he got me i no longer
have a spear captain anyone have planks
please rescue your captain there's
planks in the oh yep
i got you captain
being right by the bed is a dangerous
way to live
well that was a productive oh here he
comes ah how did i not stab you
he's dead
he's just sad harvest his very essence
yes his essence and then cook it i will
cook it we get some planks on the
cooking apple rather
captain no never mind
oh
shark is over put it in the cook put it
in the cook box i didn't put
uh porky fish a blow blow a blowfish
that's it
well uh
don't hurt hooty yeah there is one
blowfish blower in one of the storages
the dick bird it was the dick bird now
did you not hear his terrifying
keep the feet moving i didn't move got
what you deserved i say underwater where
no one can hear
[Laughter]
the rp rules in this raft are real loose
okay
here you don't hear it's really none of
our business so where is it
[Music]
ah captain where was that boar uh in the
same place it was the same one that just
respawned
infinite hide
oh yeah we could just stay here and farm
the absolute [ __ ] out of some boar maybe
the trees will come back all right i'm
going back underwater captain
good good man good man
best man
first
first second best perfect um is there a
i'm seeing a whole lot down here captain
i feel like it's been fished out
maybe maybe except for the exploding
fish
maybe maybe may ah yeah i didn't keep my
feet moving it's my own fault
oh god don't do it don't it's doing it
it did it nothing good
guys
captain where's the where's the boat
where am i yep uh
up here i don't know
are you on the surface i was i went back
down
i think it was back
to let you know yeah
it seems like he may be coming in your
general direction
funny joke captain funny joke hilarious
yeah well we'll find out always with
your pranks i'm gonna come back now oh
wait no i'm drowning
gotta get that oxygen tell you what i've
got a few problems here captain
oh i am far away all right well we'll
just raise the anchor we'll just we'll
just sail right oh oh god okay you got a
little fish when it wakes back up you
got a little bit i get it's all good so
uh captain that was a completely
fruitless adventure i found nothing of
value
excellent work thank you
let us go i wish that our thingy would
turn how do you can you how do i rotate
the raft maybe like pick it up and put
it back down maybe it broke well i mean
it's kind of working i just mean i wish
that the raft would face the direction
oh we're on a run on a rock this will
work this will work this will work we're
twisting captain perfect
now our nets are orientated in the
perfect direction to capture many things
okay
where are these things captain they'll
spawn in a moment
with us right now captain
uh no
hey whoa come on now what has cappy ever
led you wrong before i mean i'm not
saying you have i'm not saying you
haven't
after the amazingly successful island
expedition we just had you're about to
give me grief about this right now no i
i am about to give you a
flag
oh hell yeah maybe i should put that on
your bad bad should i put that on your
building absolutely i see what you're
thinking and that's a good idea run with
that all right running mate type ideas
yes it is isn't it it's pretty
incredible it really is
that's exactly the thing that i
would do
pretty good captain right if a person
hadn't done it then maybe they aren't
first mate
well i don't know uh what else what else
might a first mate do hard to say you're
a bore a crier blowfish
i did those things
i'm the guy you are first mate material
i've always said oh wow good good ass
kissing i like you
thank you you're better captain material
i've always said captain
uh derivative ass kissing i've been told
oh whoa
watch
excuse you
and a whispered voice only you can hear
i'll kill you
in a whispered voice that the captain
can almost hear oh my god how dare you
threaten another
passenger on this vessel
i
but also i said it better than it
sounded
the captain is that whispering i hear
over there
were you were you telling compliments
about this vessel what was going on oh
yes i captain we were ashamed of how
much our compliments were good and but
not good enough for how great this
vessel truly is
well you're right and also
weirding me out
wow okay you good
hi first mate do you need to be relieved
of your duty for medical reasons i i
relieved yes of duty no
i learned how to open book don't worry
guys
captain can read now wow
the smartest of us
i truly am these collection nets take a
lot captain
they do i they do i built many of them
what evidence evidence do you have in
that claim
video recorded evidence
sounds sketchy
pirates don't have video recorded
evidence are you from the future uh raft
hoe
don't change this yes we are
on a raft
and you be a hunter you're fired
there'll be a raft
i'm doing it i see him we're going oh
why did i choose you what did i tell you
when i when i dubbed you taller than the
other one i don't know we should stand
side by side and you should see who's
taller
wait wait wait hold on okay wait hold on
wait
oh all right we'll stand side by side
uh okay
looking
don't jump jumping jumping is clearly a
violation of the rules
your name hovers over your head okay uh
one of you is taller
and more terrifying but it's not the one
anymore terrifying the shark that we've
defeated or the blowfish
uh whoever gets the stuff off the raft
that we're sailing towards first is the
first mate
sharky
speed got it captain hey i got it
captain got it captain
i got it i'll be back first guys i'll be
back first you have to actually you have
to actually throw the stuff at me
oh
and what is that that
oh what's happening oh it's being
shifted around
uh
well
i have to say
mark is the only one who actually
successfully handed me anything
[Music]
i think
martin luther whispered i'll [ __ ]
kill you hey don't talk to your first
mate like that second mate
it's not roll the wheel of captain right
it's not his fault yeah well i was kind
of thinking it's about to i ran the
whole island expedition this shit's
exhausting i don't want to be captain
anymore oh okay well let's get in that
[ __ ] let's get out of here all right
let me i gotta load it up hold on
let's see am i am i still first made if
i don't get captain uh that sounds like
it's a decision the captain has to make
hmm all right who is captain
listen the discord oh i thought you were
gonna say something as you played you
holy [ __ ] i won a wheel thing you
[ __ ] are above second mate
oh okay well that's i feel like first
mate because i can only truly depend on
myself
[Music]
oh